bonsoir d'experts keynes merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france on en
parle moins aux états unis parce que
évidemment c'est l investiture hier de
joe biden qui a pris toute la place
comment réagissent les pros trump après
l'officialisation de son départ de la
maison blanche ce qu'il y ait une forme
de résignation faut se rappeler
lorsqu'on prend à des partisans de notre
hub que prince n'est pas le tout coeur
n'est pas au coeur de notre occupation
ne s'agit pas d'une secte basé sur une
personnalité
c'est pour moi une grande partie des
américains
parti très large des américains qui
connaissent bien la constitution les
lois fondatrices du pays qui sont encore
aujourd'hui complètement jeunes
rappliquer et là aux amendements est que
tout ce que fait le gouvernement fédéral
et qui le gall les états les régions et
les villes devraient décider de beaucoup
de sujets que c'est approprié le
gouvernement fédéral non ce n'est pas
légal
ce n'est pas une bonne journée au niveau
physique voire un seul gouvernement qui
étant de pouvoir sur terre de décisions
tout structure la vie des gens est
arrivé de manière très franche
parfois ils utilisaient déjà séduit pas
mais en tout cas il a remis au centre
des préoccupations ce que devrait être
la vie américaine pour ta libertés
notamment la liberté de faire ce que
l'on souhaite sans que les états unis
récupère les fruits de notre labeur ou
plus j'ai des lois qui vous empêche de
faire ce que la déclaration
d'indépendance permet de faire ce n'est
pas une secte c'est un mouvement un
retour vers l'école ste fondateur
américain
les gens sont reconnaissants envers de
la trappe pour son service et et cherche
maintenant d'autres voies pour avancer
dans ce programme
washington a l'impression donnée d'avoir
construit un mur mais ils seront surpris
mais vous dites c'est pas une secte
effectivement donald trump qui on le
rappelle quand même à rassembler 75
millions de 20 ans aux états unis le 3
novembre
c'est le jeu on le voit le nouveau
président à signer des décrets qui
annulé certaines des décisions de donald
trump par donald trump l'avait fait
avant lui il ya quatre ans pour annuler
des décisions de barack obama
quelles sont les décisions que les
républicains aujourd'hui regrette le
plus c'est sur lesquels joe biden
revient il a supprimé le projet
d'oléoduc de gazoducs qui apporterait et
rouge tunique à celui là à des
raffineries
c'était un projet qu'obama n'accepte pas
être de l'étreinte que la valider et
adjoint devait mettre un terme
donc ce sont des dizaines de milliers de
personnes qui vont perdre leur emploi
alors qu'il l'a travaillé jusqu'à
l'arrivée du virus à dubaï a également
relancé la participation que c'est à
nous et à l'accord de paris
cela va rendre la situation difficile va
renforcer les impôts pour les
entreprises et pour la population
américaine sans aucun retour immédiat à
pas
c'est le contrôle du climat je suis un
peu méfiant je ne pense pas que le
climat
écoute je ne pense pas qu'il va faire ce
qu'on me dit de faire et je pense que
dépenser de l'argent pour ce sujet c'est
de l'argent perdu
obama comme subalterne penser le
contraire et maintenant nous devons pas
versé de l'argent à d'autres pays car
nous sommes une économie florissante je
ne pense pas que nous devrions être puni
pour cela je pense qu'on devrait plutôt
nous essayé essayé de nous imiter et les
accords de paris font au contraire que
la liste des réussites de donald trump
se réunit à bercy aussi rapidement que
possible car joe biden et son équipe
voit que la mémoire même de 30 soit
s'est effacé de la mémoire du public de
washington du gouvernement qui ils
veulent que ce soit comme s'il n'avait
jamais existé pour deux ans pour les
produire et pour avoir l'air de l'eau
afin que le prochain de la trump voit ce
qui est arrivé à donald trump la façon
dont télécopies et des sites peut-être
deux n'ont paniqué de ne pas se porter
candidat à la présidence
c'est une façon d'influencer l'avenir en
faisant un exemple de donald trump alors
dr kinsey l'ancien président a laissé
une lettre à son successeur que joe
biden a qualifié je cite de généreuses
est-ce que vous avez une petite idée de
ce qu'il aurait pu lui dire par écrit de
la trompe et c'est un gentleman une
personne devra une personne gentille
avec une fois que la compétition est
terminée
une fois de plus la peine de se battre
il est passé il est aussi gentille assez
long que toute autre personne
je pense que c'était une lettre très
très généreuse effectivement qui lui a
souhaité bonne chance
on en parle évidemment depuis déjà
plusieurs semaines mais plus que jamais
en tout cas pour les partisans dont vous
faites parti de donald trump comment
vous voyez le le futur proche on a parlé
de la création d'un parti mais il faudra
d'abord que le président sortant
franchise certains obstacles judiciaires
n'est ce pas cela rentre dans cette
émission dont je vous parlais il ya
quelques instants
il s'agit de rendre la situation aussi
difficile que possible notre pour donald
trump afin qu'il serve d'exemple que la
situation semble trop complexe pour d'or
qui voudraient imiter son exemple donc
effectivement cela rentre dans ce
tunisien qui continue une fois la
présence terminée et s'il ne résiste pas
à le détruire complètement
je pense qu'il va renoncer à un empire
médiatique
il va a lancé d'une belle chaîne à
maintenir sur internet
c'est un de ses objectifs depuis très
longtemps et je pense que maintenant
qu'on se rend compte que les médias
traditionnels américains dérive vers la
gauche vers le démocrate et bien il ne
pourrait les populations pourraient
décider de se tourner vers cet empire a
créé par donald trump
cela serait vraiment une chance pour
donald trump qui pourrait offrir une
voie un peu plus conservatrice dans les
médias et je pense qu'il a le nez creux
en matière de finances et je pense qu'il
sentira bien je n'imagine pas commencer
un nouveau parti je pense que c'est plus
compliqué parce c'est valorisant les un
média à nos pires des médias
conservateurs
je pense que c'est une une solution
intéressante merci beaucoup de fatigue
d'avoir été avec nous pour vu de
l'extérieur ce soir